alright ok what can we do with this
thing what can we possibly and you won't
want to suggest like what can I um
what can I try the only one give me
suggestion ok
now be super careful I've I've written
this letter I was gonna say a letter for
letter but it's not just let his his
characters as well okay
character for character brackets kind of
make a difference alright it kind of
made a big difference actually
now what's your probably thinking of
what you probably think you have is this
scenario right this is the powerful now
what's happening here is that square
what's being squared in this scenario
it's just that a in fact really this
should be brackets there just to make a
super obvious okay whereas here I am not
squaring just the two I'm squaring the
whole thing okay so you can't just bring
that to out the front okay any more than
you can say oh yeah x squared that's
definitely 2x you can't just say I
unless X is soup okay so so I can't do
that that's a different kind of scenario
right so what else could I do
do I have any options I multiplied this
two by this square okay let's think
about what this means like if I just
pedal back you said it might want to or
square when you have something and it's
squared
what is squaring me multiply myself yeah
multiplied by itself right so just law 2
times 1/2 that's what a really means
okay
now log 2 times log 2 when you multiply
those things is that is that really like
log 4 is it it's not is it
okay you might be thinking of this that
is law for but nope that's not what
we're doing when multiplying them okay
so therefore these these kind of steps
they're they're no good right so what
else could I possibly do for you what
options do I have
say again
put it into the calculator okay now I
think I'm ahead you just go ahead you
got calculus give it a shot see what
happens I'd like you to try something
something quite when I think you're
doing the best you are confusing this
right it's not it's not that bad I'm
glad you're giving your stuff it's like
when you multiply numbers with in index
form right Exponential's that's when you
add right so can I say one of the
dangers are when learning logs you know
which is okay but you can confuse a
function with its inverse
it's a great which one is adding tells
you to multiply and which one's the
other way around you're thinking about
the other way around because when you
multiply these you add but when you
what's the numbers not shoot when you
add logs that's when you multiply okay
which by the way is a bit of a tip
because I am adding logs on time
learning more to this unless you this
and this I can do some I can do some
multiplication right
but what kind of multiplication can I
even do here yeah if you want to log to
you'll get log 2 to the power of 2
because no I don't know I don't cuz I'm
not I'm not adding the laws I'm
multiplying it in fact I don't really
have I'll tell you right now I don't
have a wall for what happens when you
just want to apply these laws okay so
what else can I do I know I'll make this
mention I I wrote down the side there
when a log doesn't have a base attached
to it and when it's written like this
you guys have the unenviable dilemma
I'm seeing a position where it's like
well you know what you kind of don't
thoroughly know what they mean okay um
for example on your calculator I've
already told you what molecule database
means it means based in okay but if you
go into unit make see which I have a lot
of it you will those textbooks when they
write this there do not mean based in
there like I'm a mathematician you know
go away I would base eighty that's the
important base right here
I don't know and probably point is that
it's immaterial to the question okay and
why people have been just [ __ ] to make
a case have not been getting yes could
accept a lot all right let me let me
rewind a little
we've everybody up against a brick wall
okay and that's not a bad thing that's
not a bad thing you Thomas Edison he
said you know you've made ten thousand
light bulbs that haven't worked right
why do you keep trying it's like it's
not failures then just I know now the
ways that I don't need to try and that
opens up like now I know restrictions I
should go in okay what other kinds of
tools like you've exhausted
you really have exhausted your lawn
mowers here right what else could you
possibly do I could try to change a base
law except for not knowing what the
faces okay let me suggest to you humbly
this okay oh wait you see something like
this do you know what to do don't you
but you look at that you think oh okay
this is a quadratic because things are
squared right
okay now you look at this right I see
things are square I don't get anywhere
obvious when I try mile or more
manipulation because you're not supposed
to do not normally search and it's not
yet okay
this is something square I'll give you a
bit of a clue there is something in here
right this log to swear walk for I can
join make do something like want to
write is it not log to square isn't it
now that's a power I can do something
with I can move that guy right that's
going to be in fact to log to do you
agree with that that's what log for is
times log 5 plus
log five-o squared okay you're right
with that okay now I want you to look at
that really carefully look at that
really really carefully I know that
there's logs in there making this messy
but if I write this instead you would
recognize that wouldn't you
come on we spent weeks on quadratics
right that is a perfect square that's
why we had to do completing the square
blah blah blah blah blah something
squared something else square double the
product of each tell me what to write
tell me what's right does this not look
like if it's a squared plus 2ab
impossible this is a plus b walls we're
okay with that yes it must be elsewhere
because it looks like this this by
definition is how a perfect square will
be okay if I see if I see x squared plus
2x plus 1 right because of my breaking
quadratics I said I know what that is
that X plus 1 all squared okay and this
is exactly the same it's just a big mess
so this is my a this a squared this is
my to a B and this is my B squared so
this looks to me like log tune hey must
be swell right okay now your ever I said
before are you don't know you don't
really know when it does get written for
you here clearly because remember I told
you guys you're not really supposed to
know what E is right so therefore your
assumption is 10 when you add numbers
with the same base because no base is
written the same base what happens if
you've tied right log 10 squared and
it's clearly base 10 right so this is
log base 10 of 10 which is one square
which is